in a country with the population of more
than 160 million fewer than 3,000 have
been tested for the virus that's one of
the lowest testing rates anywhere many
hospitals all over Bangladesh are
turning away patients even the
critically ill because of fears of
coronavirus infection all Musudan died
last week after he was denied treatment
at six different hospitals in the
capital the veteran freedom fighter of
the war of independence in Bangladesh
was a brain hemorrhage patient suffering
from mild pneumonia
his only daughter says the healthcare
system is failing to serve the people
even after admitting him they later
discharged him and refused treatment
I could understand those who didn't have
the gear might be at risk but many of
the doctors had full protective
equipment some of these hospitals had
corona isolation units why didn't they
admit or treat him Bangladesh is Health
Minister has issued a warning to
healthcare professionals this is not the
time to backtrack on your duties and it
is not justified at all stand by the
people and serve them recently we have
noticed the dereliction of duty the
warning came too little too late for
Sharon referred OC her sister-in-law
died recently because of what she calls
medical negligence my sister-in-law was
diagnosed with gastrointestinal disease
at a City Hospital in Khulna she had a
successful surgery there but on 25th
March further treatment was denied after
the surgery since there was a corona
virus patient who died in that hospital
the previous night media reports hearsay
more than fifty bangladesh's died
recently from respiratory illness
symptoms similar to corona virus but the
government didn't record their death as
virus link the reports say health
experts say the expected high number of
patient during the summer worries them
because many of their symptoms will
probably be similar to the corona virus
but many hospitals in the city remain
closed and refused to admit any patients
it recently leaked UN memo warned that
Bangladesh is facing up to 2 million
deaths from their pandemic if immediate
and appropriate steps aren't taken
Dunwich Audrey al-jazeera Dhaka
Bangladesh